so fundamentally what is the problem
with the state
that's existence
okay well but but uh to play angel's
advocate again
you know government is the people
so come on you don't you you you're
saying do you do you really think this
at as best i think it's possible to have
represent representation
can you imagine if you have an attorney
you're like oh you can't have the
attorney you want you're gonna have this
guy who you absolutely hate who you
share no values with why
because he drives i mean leaders
political leaders and
political representation drive the
discourse like we you know
uh the majority of people voted for him
or whatever
however however you define that and
now we get to have a discussion well
was this the right choice and then we
get to make that choice again
in four years and so on first of all the
fact that i have to be under the thumb
of somebody for four years
makes no sense there's no other
relationship that's like this including
a marriage
uh you can leave any other relationship
at any time number one
number two is you'd always impeach but
they did that part of it i'm
in just saying that there's the
mechanisms
are flawed in many ways yeah yeah right
and and
so that's number one number two is it
doesn't make sense
that if i don't want someone to
represent me
that because that person is popular that
they are now in a position to so
having uh um representation and and
having citizenship
based on geography is a pre-land line
technology in a post-cell phone world
there's no reason why i have to just
because we're physically in
between two oceans we all have to be
represented by the same people
whereas i can very easily have my
security be under someone and switch it
as easily as cell phone providers
so okay but it doesn't have to be
geographical it can be ideas
sure i mean this country represents a
certain set of ideas yes it does it
started out geographically
it still it was just it started off as
ideas as well but like there's a it's
it was intricately i mean that's the way
humans are there's
i mean there was no internet so
it was you were geographically in the
same location and you signed a bunch of
documents and then you kind of debated
and you
wrote a bunch of stuff and then you
agreed on it
okay so do you understand that no one
signed these documents and no one agreed
to it
as lysandra spooner pointed out over 150
years ago
the constitution or the social contract
if anything is only binding to the
signatories
um and even then they're all long dead
uh so it's it's this
fallacy that somehow because i'm in a
physical place
i've agreed even though i'm screaming
through a face that i don't agree
to be um subordinate to uh some
imaginary invisible monster that was
created 250 years ago
uh and this idea of like if you don't
like it you have to move that's not what
freedom means
freedom means i do what i want not what
you want so if you don't like it
you move okay just to put some i don't
like words
and terms one one one zero one one one
zero yeah exactly what your language
like
it is i'm translating it all in real
time but
uh would you call the kind of ideas
that uh you're advocating for and we're
talking about anarchy
yes anarchism yes okay so let's get into
it can you
can you try to paint the utopia
that an anarchist worldview dreams about
the only people who describe anarchism
as utopia are its critics
if i told you right now and i wish i
could say this factually that i have a
cure for cancer
that would not make us utopia uh that
would still probably be expensive
uh we would still have many other
diseases however we would be
fundamentally
healthier happier and better off all
of us than democracy so that democracy i
jump back from the cancer no that
democracy or
or government so it's only curing one
major
major life-threatening problem but in no
sense
is it a utopia so what can we try to uh
answer this question same question many
times which is
what exactly is the problem with
democracy the problem with democracy is
that those who need leaders are not
qualified to choose them
those who need leaders are not qualified
to choose them so uh that's the central
problem of democracy not all of us need
leaders right
what does it mean to need a leader are
you saying like people who are
actually like free thinkers don't need
leaders kind of thing
sure but like work but like you don't
okay so do you acknowledge that there's
some
value in authority
in different subjects so what what that
means is i don't mean authority somebody
who's in control of you but
you're doing the definition switch
because i am i am you're right you're
right it's unfair okay those
those bad that's what they do that's
their trick yeah and it's this is
one of the useful things by the way
leslie's total sidebar if people ask me
for advice
i always tell them if you're going to
raise your kids raise them bilingual
because i was trilingual by the time i
was six and that teaches you to think in
concepts
whereas if you only know one language
you fall for things like this because
using authority in the sense of a
policeman
and someone is an authority in physics
it's the same word
conceptually they're extremely different
but if you're only thinking in one
language
your brain is going to equate the two
and that's a trap that people who only
speak one language have
for sure but even if you know multiple
languages you can still use the trick of
using your c or convenience
yeah absolutely to manipulate the
conversation that you weren't trying to
do
but you you fell i accidentally did it
yeah you're right we all tend to do that
if you only speak one language and think
of one language
but if i guess let me rephrase it i
are you against do you acknowledge the
value
of like offloading your own
effort about a particular thing to
somebody else absolutely like an
accountant a lawyer a doctor absolute a
chef
infinite isn't that ultimately what a
democracy is
broadly defined like you you're
basically electing a bunch of
authorities using the word you in two
senses using the word you meaning me as
an individual now using you as a mass
yeah as a as a math not use an
individual so i
have i would absolutely want someone to
provide for my security
i would absolutely want someone to
negotiate with me for foreign power or
something like that
that does not mean it has to be
predicated and what lots of other people
who i do not
know and if i do knew them probably
would not respect think about
it's of no moral relevance to me
nor eye to them so do you think this
kind of there could be
a bunch of humans that behave kind of
like
ants in a distributed way there could be
an emergent behavior in them that
results in a stable society like
it's not the hope with anarchy is like
without
an overarching uh uh but answer i i mean
answer the worst example here because
ants have a very firm authority
the queen yeah and they're all they're
all drones they're all clones of each
other
yeah but so if you forget the queen
their behavior they're all
well from your perspective from your
human intelligence perspective
but from their perspective they'll
probably see each other as a bunch of
individuals
no they don't ants are very big on
altruism in the sense of self-sacrifice
they do not think the individual matters
they routinely
kill themselves for the sake of the
hives in the community but they
see that's from the outside perspective
from the individual perspective of the
individual they probably
they they don't see it as altruism
right but they they view and they're
right because the ant's life is very
ephemeral and cheap
that it's more important to continue
this mass population that
that one individual ant live like bees
are another even better example the
honey bee
when they sting they only sting once and
they die and they do it gladly because
it's like okay
this community is much more important
than me and they're right
yeah okay so fine let's forget i'm being
pedantic but it's important i think i'm
not
just being for the sake of being
pedantic but there's something beautiful
that
i won't argue about because i do there's
an interesting point there about
individualism of ants
i do think they're more individual that
but look let's
let's give your view of ants that
they're it's they're communists okay
let's go with the communist view of ants
okay yeah uh
but there's still a beautiful emergent
thing which is like
they can function as a as a society
and without i would say
centralized control
yeah it's another argument so is that
the hope for anarchy it's like
you just throw a bunch of people that
voluntarily want to be in the same place
under the same set of ideas and they
kind of like
the doctors emerge the police officers
emerge
the uh the different necessary
structures of a functional society
emerge
do you know what the most beautiful
example of anarchism is
that it's just beyond beautiful when you
stop to think about it
i'm not being tongue-in-cheek language
there's infinite languages language the
things that language can be used for
are bring tears to people's eyes quite
literally
it's also used for basic things no one
is forcing us
we speak two languages each at least no
one's forcing us to use english
no one's forcing us to use this dialect
of english uh
it's a way and and despite there being
so many different languages
uh lingua franca emerge you know people
the language that everyone is in latin
even in north korea they refer to the
fish and the different animals by the
latin
scientific uh no one decided this sure
there's an organization
that sets a binomial nomenclature but
there's no gun to anyone's head
referring to seamoth as a pegasus
species
and when you think about how amazing
language is
and and someone other context would say
like well you you need to have a world
government
and they're deciding which is the verbs
and you have to have an official
definition
and an official dictionary and none of
that happened and
i think anyone even if they don't agree
with my politics or my worldview
cannot deny that the creation of
language is
one of humanity's most miraculous
beautiful achievements
absolutely so there there you go there's
one system where
a kind of anarchy can result in
in beauty stability like sufficient
stability and yet
dynamic flexibility to adjust it and so
on
and the internet helps it you get some
something like urban dictionary yeah
which starts creating absurd both humor
and
wit but also language and syntax and
jargon immediately you size people up
if you use if you say vertebral i know
you're a doctor because that's how they
pronounce it the the
spinal column uh i'm sure in your field
there's certain
jargon right away you can know if this
person is one of us or not i mean
it's infinite i mean i don't need to
tell you and it's emojis
too yes there's so much there to study
with language it's fascinating
but do you think this applies to human
life
the the meat space the physical space
yes so
these that kind of beauty can emerge
without
uh without writing stuff on paper
without laws you could have rules you
don't need to you don't have to be laws
so enforced by violence like that's what
what's a law a law is something that is
unchosen
a rule is something if i go to my pool
you know
i sign up to remember a pool on the wall
lists certain things it's like you know
certain number of people in the pool no
peeing in here good luck enforcing that
one
um and so on and so forth well that's
the problem aren't you afraid that
people are gonna pee in the pool
that's not as my bigger concern as mass
incarceration
as the fact that the police can steal
more money than burglars can
the fact that innocent people can be
killed with no consequences
the fact that war can be waged and with
no
uh uh consequences for those who waged
it the fact that so many
men and women are being murdered
overseas and here and the people who are
guiding these are regarded as heroic
so you think there might that in an
anarchist system
there's a possibility of have of having
less wars and less what would you say
corruption
and uh less abuse of power let's talk
yes and let's talk about corruption
because and i made this point on rogan
you and i
again this the russian background we
realize
that when it comes to corruption
american is very naive
corruption they think is oh i got my
brother a job and he's getting money on
the table
that's not when we're talking about like
state corruption
things that are done in totalitarian
states and even to some extent in
america like jeffrey epstein julian
maxwell
things that stalin did things that
hitler did you know when the cia was
torturing people at gitmo
they had to borrow kgb manuals because
they didn't know how to torture
correctly because they never thought of
these things
we it's very hard for us to get into the
mindset of someone who's like a child
predator
someone who uh let me give you an
example from my forthcoming book there
was a guy who was the head of ukraine
in the 30s i forget his name now these
old soviets they were tough
i mean they pride stalin means steel you
know they pride themselves in their
cruelty
and how strong they were and this was
the purge you know stalin is trying to
you know killing lots of people left and
right
and his henchman beria had the quote
uh find me the man and i'll find you the
crime you know they would accuse someone
and they would torture him
until he talked and confessed and then
he had to turn people in
and they took this guy in like beginning
the year i think it's 36 38 he was had
ukraine
by may he's arrested and they take him
to the le blanca the basement in the red
square where they're torturing people
and they put they did the works on him
and he was a good soviet and he stood up
then
who knows what they did to him he didn't
talk so they said
okay one moment they brought his teenage
daughter in
raped her in front of him he talked so
when we talk about corruption we
would never in a million years think of
this that's not how our minds work
um so when you're talking about states
and people
where you don't have ease of exit
where you are forced to be under the
auspices of an organization
creating a monopoly that leads to
in extreme cases but in not as extreme
cases
really uh nefarious outcomes whereas
if you have the option to leave as a
client or customer
that would have a strongly limiting
effect
on how a business and what it can get
away with
you